Pluto for example there is every chance
that life could have started there a new
species of dog yeah
one of the ways that we first go out
into the solar system to look for life
is not to look for life itself initially
we're just going to look for
environments like we've been doing on
Mars we're looking for those kind of
saline and watery environments that
might have hasted life in the past you
then get to the exoplanets so far away
we can't directly see them initially
we're just looking for whether the
planet is hot or cold and how close it
is to its its star a Goldilocks zone the
Goldilocks zone is sort of being a
little bit disproven more recently
because
um we're starting to now in our solar
system see environments like Pluto for
example not in the Goldilocks zone but
it's geologically active and you know
there is every chance that life could
have started there um because it's got
all kind of the right conditions a new
species of dog yeah it's labradoodles
all over